hello my name is Brett Davidson and I'm
here with my colleague eka gurgurk and
we're from the ncsu libraries here in
Raleigh North Carolina if you'd like to
get at our slides they're available here
I'll give you a moment to grab that of
course you can just look up here or two
if you prefer so our agenda for the day
we're going to take a look at open
science as a problem space and then
we're going to reframe open science as
modern research practice and we'll talk
a little bit about what we've been doing
at NC State particularly in the
libraries to engage researchers on
campus in open science and then show you
how we're using vagrant ansible and
Python to help researchers develop what
we are seeing evolving as a modern
research skill set so this is our
contract if this isn't what you expected
to see or you've changed your mind you
have a few minutes to leave before we
lock the doors so about 400 years ago
the royal Philips philosophical society
published the first journal really in
science called the philosophical
transactions which covered the outputs
of the ingenious people in the world
they have this really handy motto called
nullius in verba which translates
roughly to take nobody's word for it
well if we fast-forward 400 years it
turns out that they were quite prescient
we can't actually take anyone's word for
it or at least that's what this article
published in 2012 in nature tried to get
us to believe when it's cited that vast
majority of cancer studies could not be
reproduced and this gained a lot of
traction in the media you've probably
seen this barrage of discussion of
reproducibility difficulties over the
past few years in the media in this term
has kind of come to the surface coined
by the media rightly or wrongly as a
reproducibility crisis this is still
evolving and maybe the aggressiveness of
this term has been scaled back a little
bit over the past year but there still
seems to be a strong sentiment among
science researchers and researchers
generally that reproducibility is a big
challenge
so when we're talking about open science
it's really an umbrella term for a
number of open practices that you all
may be involved in it different in a
different composition in your own work
whether that's open access to research
outputs or open data open notebooks or
of course open source software really
though the philosophy of open science is
returned to the first principles of
scientific practice and there's a pretty
strongly held belief that open science
can improve reproducibility however
these open practices require new skill
sets so my colleague eka is going to
come up and give us a little bit more
insight into what open science is hi
everyone if you can't hear me wave or
gesture or something because I'm
generally kind of soft spoken so as
Brett mentioned open science is this
really broad umbrella term and to really
contextualize it and to give it some
form I'm going to lean on a definition
that was crowd sourced from
practitioners it is an umbrella term
that encompasses a multitude of
assumptions about the future of
knowledge creation and dissemination and
that's really important to kind of keep
in the back of your mind as we're going
through this it's really about the way
that research is carried out the way
that research is disseminated and how
digital technologies in particular are
affecting the practice of science a lot
of the terminology and conceptualization
around the open science comes from the
open source movement so there are
terminological crossover is there's a
lot of iconography that kind of crosses
over between the two but the term itself
was coined by paul david in the early
2000s and he's an economist and a
historian which i think is really
important to note because this term did
not come from the scientific community
initially it was kind of framed in the
context of the knowledge economy and
this idea that the global economy is
shifting towards knowledge objects not
material goods being very important and
that
science or openness in scientific
practice is one way for science to
maintain relevance and to become more
impactful going forward in this
transition but of course open science
isn't a new idea science in the modern
sense as we know it has always been open
and again going back to this idea of
nullius in verba take nobody's word form
for it the openness in everything you do
is what reinforces that truthfulness
this is about the increasing fertility
of traditional openness and open science
itself is a response to this crisis of
rep reduce ability which could also be
termed a crisis of the scientific method
and that's again a fairly controversial
statement because of course science can
keep going even amid crisis it's not
it's not like everything's coming to a
standstill just because there's a crisis
of reproducibility it's kind of a
broader structural issue and I think
it's useful to understand it by going
back to what the scientific method
really is and many of us in this room
are familiar with it but I think it's
useful to step through it anyways
essentially science is not truth it's a
truth making process that is exploratory
in nature it's about asking questions of
nature through experimentation
uncovering possible answers to those
questions and sharing these answers so
that others may question them and the
loss of rep reduce ability is really the
loss of that last sentence it's just
sharing these answers to generate truth
rather than having that double check
it's a trust action and again this is
all very theoretical really high level
and an umbrella term so Csonka buckling
and Sasha face whose names i will never
pronounce correctly came up with five
schools of thought to kind of comfort
mentalize the way that people are
approaching open science broadly the
first is this idea of infrastructure so
actually building out technological
solutions to support open practice
and the next is this idea of public
public science which is about the
accessibility of knowledge creation
particularly for publicly funded
research and making that research
accessible to the public that funded it
as well as bringing the public in
through citizen science efforts which
means normal everyday people can
actually contribute to scientific
practice to research as it's ongoing
then there's the measurement school
which is about alternative impacts and
essentially this takes into account the
fact that we did the rise of digital
technologies the way that you measure
what your research has impacted what it
is done has shifted social media metrics
are an example of alternative in fact
measurement there's a democratic school
which is related to the public but it's
more global is this idea that access to
scientific information is a human right
it's something that's cross national
international it's across countries it's
across communities within a country
across socio-economic barriers and it's
fundamentally about the access to
knowledge which means not only making it
available but making it understandable
by all of these different groups so
enabling that translation and finally
there's a pragmatic school which
basically just takes into account the
fact that a lot of scientific problems
require a lot of brainpower more than
you can house under one roof in one lab
it's too expensive too maybe the skill
sets aren't all in one place at the same
time so the pragmatic school is about
taking into account these new challenges
from the difficulty of conducting some
kinds of research and just bringing
people together to make it happen and
again this has been really big in the
news lately a useful way to consent
contextualize all these broad ideas is
through newspaper articles and this is
going back to cancer reproducibility
study it was really big news in the
early 2010's
and then also to contextualize it is not
just a science problem it's a social
science problem as well um there's this
great article by The Washington Post on
austerity measures and the fact that a
lot of the policy surrounding the
service aerating measures came from a
research article that was published
without open data and there was an Excel
error that actually shifted one of their
results vary slightly the authors of
that original paper have sensed said
that despite that error their
conclusions are still roughly the same
but it's scary to think that nobody
noticed the error while making policies
based on this research policies that
impacted the international community and
this is an example of citizen science in
the news recently the Flint Michigan
water crisis was kind of broken out and
made public but through a citizen
science effort community members
contributing to the betterment of their
community and finally the Zika virus
there's been a push by the scientific
community internationally to make the
drug discovery process for Zika open and
it is open right now one of the big
quotes from this paper was that there
there's likely already data that could
contribute to drug discovery process in
proprietary environments not accessible
internationally as it could be were it
open so that's open science that's kind
of a broad context why our library is
interested in this we are from the north
carolina state university libraries this
is one of our wonderful libraries the
hunt library essentially open science
aligns with the core library values such
as information access peer review
community-based knowledge creation and
the preservation dissemination of
research it's really aligned with what
we do and open science is really
reflective of modern research practice
as it is forming and libraries are also
champions of open source and open
everything we're very big on enabling
access to information
and we're fundamentally about supporting
our users we've always been a
user-centric environment for academic
libraries such as ours that means
supporting research practice in whatever
form it takes and all of this is to say
that modern research practice is
experiencing this ongoing disruption
from digital technologies which is then
impacting the way that we do our work so
it's very important for us to engage
with it and to again contextualize that
disruption here's the hypothetical open
science workflow from the 101
innovations in scholarly communication
project which is an awesome survey that
asks researchers to report what tools
they're using on a regular basis across
I every year once a year they've been
doing it for over a decade and you can
kind of see that digital technologies
have really integrated into every piece
of the research lifecycle and that's
useful to kind of understand how deep
this engagement is and how diverse it is
there's also a broad policy shift and
supportive open this is a an OECD
science and technology policy paper
called making open science a reality the
US has been an OECD member since the 60s
and our policies here are directly
influenced by these international
decisions and this is increasingly
important for grant requirements a lot
of grants are requiring researchers to
state open data deposit open publication
so in order for research to happen in
order to people to for people to get the
money to do what they need to do they
need to be aware of these issues so we
went on an initiative to explore open
science in NC State and that's
specifically within the ncsu libraries
the open science initiative Brett my
representative of it and our goal is
really to explore open science practice
at ncsu in our unique context and to
better understand understand researcher
needs in our context
and we did this through a very
non-prescriptive user-centered approach
a lot of user research went into it
which of course means creating
opportunities for communication
communication being the big deal you
have to talk to your users to understand
what they genuinely need we hosted an
open science unconference locally and
had faculty attend and kind of talk to
us about what open science meant to them
practically and then conducted formal
informal follow-up interviews with
anybody who expressed interest in the
unconference essentially and we kind of
found two major issues that were
universal across the board would anybody
we talk to there's a perceived modern
research skills gap there's a sense that
there are skills out there that you need
as a researcher that intersect with your
work in some way would enable modes of
work that you're not engaged with yet
but you don't quite know how to pick
them up or which direction to go in
first and there's there insufficient
incentives overall to enable that the
level of exploration needed to kind of
figure out which skill set is the best
for you and so we started off with a
right off the bat trying to address this
modern research skills gap through the
summer of open science over the past
summer we held a series of ten workshops
five per summer term at our institution
designed to address some of the biggest
tools and topics that came out of this
user research and this is kind of a
general idea of our promotion we we
really shared collective knowledge
within the libraries to develop this
series and to to kind of get the content
out there this is representative of our
team all of whom come from different
departments within the libraries and it
was a series of workshops and events
around scientific computing with Python
understanding your scholarly identity as
well as a series of meetups which kind
of continued the sense of
munication and enabled community
building which we had which was one of
the goals of the initiative and this is
an example of our impact this is a
Python and scientific computing workshop
in our maker space this workshop in
particular had a 40-person wait list
which is kind of crazy if you think
about it and we found that it was there
was a very dramatic interdisciplinary
need across campus we touched over 40
departments across over 16 colleges
ranging from the humanities to
engineering to physics to anybody you
can think of and now i'm going to hand
it off to brett to talk a little bit
about how that scientific computing
would python workshop in particular was
iterated on and enabled through
technical solutions so how many of you
remember what it was like to start as a
programmer it's pretty scary experience
right you're not sure where to look for
information you may be familiar with the
phrase impostor syndrome I may be
experiencing it right now I'm not sure
it's important to note that when we're
talking about supporting researchers on
our campus there's a huge range of
support that already exists there and
our particular efforts are targeted at
identifying the people that wouldn't be
able to take advantage of something like
say PI data Carolinas or a data science
track on campus people that had the
interest and the domain expertise but
needed that first step into the
technical sphere they're obviously very
intelligent people well socialized and
if we can help them meet the right
people and give them the right starting
points they can be very successful on
their own so this web scraping with
Python course when we look at it as
experienced developers we probably look
at this list and say yeah yeah that's no
big deal I can do everything on that
list sure I know pythons data structures
I know how to import a library I know
how to use requests I know
to retrieve a webpage and scrape it sure
I've made a visualization probably more
sophisticated than a word cloud I know
what control structures are exception
handling we all do a good job of that
right and I know how to work with the
file system I can read in CSV data or
retrieve it from an API of course to a
novice none of these things are trivial
and this is what we were able to cover
in a short two-hour 45-minute workshop
but on top of these very explicit
learning outcomes related to python
skill acquisition there are a lot of
implicit skills that are assumed
oftentimes in these environments how do
you use a command line interface do you
know how to interact with a web server
on your own machine what text editor do
i use should i use for spaces or two
should i use tabs or spaces you know
these deep-seated questions that can
actually break programs in particular
languages so we were able to go a little
deeper than just some of these explicit
requirements but also some of these
implicit ones and when we first taught
this course we identified a number of
challenges for our attendees first it
was incredibly difficult to get
consistency across our user environments
I one researcher who comes in with an
eight year old windows machine someone
who comes with a linux box who thinks
they're our Linux guru but really isn't
and you have someone who uses OS 10 and
has never open the terminal before this
is great this is a representative
population but how do we teach to this
environment everyone has different
versions of Python that may not know how
to use pip that's very challenging as an
instructor which makes the creation of
course materials that can then be taken
from the classroom and used for
individual learning almost impossible if
you've ever tried to write a blog post
about a tutorial you've probably
received comments following up oh you
didn't cover my exceptional edge case I
didn't know your edge case existed if I
had I might have considered it then
there's also this challenge of how
quickly can we get a workshop up and
running you know probably it's very
difficult to make sure everyone has the
same package running the same version
and then of course how do we draw people
together from our own
organization in this case the ncsu
libraries to help contribute learning
materials to this project there are a
lot of approaches that when one could
take to sort of support this sort of
learning environment you could create
custom operating system images which end
up being pretty large may be hard to
distribute you could lean on custom
distributions like anaconda which is
marvelous of course or you could use the
really rich interactive environments
like Jupiter which we saw a lot of great
success with I think yesterday and today
the approach we elected to take was to
take a look at some virtualization tools
designed for developers and provisioning
tools designed for server management and
configuration so we used vagrant and
ansible together to help us create
lightweight localized repeatable
reproducible computing environments that
were easier for us to maintain because
the outputs of them rather than being a
large disk image were just text files
that we could put into our enterprise
github system and edit and share very
easily it's a quick show of hands how
many people have used vagrant or heard
of it how many people have used ansible
or something similar chef puppet yes
great so quick introduction for those
that aren't familiar vagrant is really
at its simplest a tool for helping to
coordinate virtual images often through
VirtualBox their ad copy says you can
create and configure lightweight
reproducible and portable development
environments and it's extremely easy to
use there's a binary installer that you
can put on your machine once you've
installed vagrants it will also install
VirtualBox you type vagrant in it and it
creates an initialization file that's
just simply a text file written in Ruby
yeah that's right in Ruby and then you
run a single command vagrant up it reads
that file and your environment is
scaffold assuming that you've plugged it
in with a provisioner and I know this is
difficult to read on this particular
screen encourage you to take a look at
the slides at home the big thing to take
away here is that this is a
txt file that's 27 lines and it wires up
the entire setup of a computing
environment that we used on 40 machines
for classroom experience the first 15
lines or so are simply about selecting a
virtual image to download and
configuring the ports to access it so
that you can view web programs on the
browser and then this last little block
is the provision or block vagrant comes
configured to work out of the box with a
number of provisioning tools in this
case we chose to use ansible and you can
just point to an ansible playbook and it
stands up your system so what is ansible
you might ask well their ad copy says
they're an automation engine for
provisioning configuration management
app deployment and other IT needs ok
provisioning means to make something
available I understood it when it told
me this means installing packages this
means putting libraries software systems
tools onto my machine that I need and
then this question of configuration
management is how do i wire these things
up so that they work with each other
consistently and repeatedly here's a
very simple example of a playbook in
this playbook the first eight lines or
so are just some metadata about the
environment that your provisioning to
and the real meat and potatoes if you
will our lines 9 10 and 11 where you
link out from your playbook to some
roles which is a sequence of
installation activities so if you
remember back to the vagrant file the
vagrant file is pointing to this
playbook when it provisions when you run
vagrant up it calls this file when which
starts ansible when ansible stands up it
says okay I need to execute these roles
and here's an example role again I
apologize for the text size essentially
though this file not following ansible
best practices for the sake of this
example but we have basically a set of
tasks that are doing the provisioning
for our environment where i'm using the
apt package manager on the unix
environment image that we downloaded to
install a number of baseline
requirements for the tutorial
environment and then
the last two directives are doing some
of the configuration management that we
needed for the environment direct a user
to the correct directory when they ssh
into vagrant and set a display variable
zoom at plot lib works through
virtualization if you want to take a
closer look at this environment you can
pull it up it's a github com and CSU
libraries python vagrant this is very
immature environment it was really a
test environment but it will give you a
sense of what what we were able to do
with it this is all so that we can make
this process of standing up an
instructional environment easy for
researchers when they come in and it
really is a five step process once they
have vagrant installed on their machine
they can clone this Python vagrant
repository or download the zip file they
navigate it navigate to it through the
command line interface execute vagrant
up after eight or ten minutes depending
on the network performance at that
particular time the vagrant environment
will be stood up with all the
requirements that you need for the
course the operating system the Python
environment the Python dependencies that
we're using and all that configuration
that we highlighted the user execute
vagrant SSH they're inside the virtual
environment and then they can execute
Python code so we've obviously put a lot
of emphasis on how we've been using
these tools to support research or
training we see this is just the very
first step for what we'd like to do as
eka said this is the result of a trend
not only of open practices and open
influences but also changes in how
research is conducted this is really why
PI data is here right is this shift
towards this huge emphasis on data
science is a core skill for for any sort
of research oriented investigatory
practice so what we want to do moving
forward is to take this sort of very
basic instructional environment move it
towards something that's better suited
to more serious scientific computing can
we expand on like the vagrant
environment that anaconda has put
together and integrate that with some
other tools that we use can we expose
for our attendees some of the things
that are under
lying this process of writing web
applications so I mentioned before that
there are a lot of implicit requirements
into a course one advantage of using
these something like ansible where
you're provisioning is that you have a
written record of what actually is
required to get the environment running
and you can expose that to the attendee
as a learning tool so that they can
understand how their environment is
working Kyle made this mention this
morning and in his keynote that I
thought was really right on target it
gives you a better sense of how the
system itself is functioning and then
we'd like to go a little further and
optimize the relationship between the
images that we pull down right now we're
just using a generic UNIX image with a
gooey but we'd like to maybe enrich that
a little bit to decide where exactly
where we're separating those concerns
and are in our process and make the
correct balance between disk images
provisioners and our tutorials and once
we go through some of this process we're
going to try to make this happen in
something we're calling scholarly
backpacks we're going to try to attack
this from three angles we want to create
a virtual environment that supports
researchers with general research tools
things like tableau for sort of very
entry-level visualization site research
citation tools and that sort of thing
but then explore more robust
environments for data science using
things like anaconda numpy sigh pie etc
and of course when is their demand for
some sort of visualization focused
research environment these days and
we're going to take these environments
and take them out on a campus and we are
early stages of finding partners for
this process but we're very confident
we'll be able to put these into
curricular use on campus to help next
generation researchers sort of get a leg
up on developing these skills but also
to test them out in our in a real
laboratory environment to see if it
holds mustard so very quickly in summary
we're arguing that an emphasis on
reproducibility and this shift in
digital tools has ignited a shift toward
new practices and research with these
new practices come new requirements for
researchers both in terms of the
infrastructure
that they're working with but also in
terms of the skill set that they have
themselves an outgrowth of this is that
reproducible and portable computing
environments are critical for future
success we need to be able to reproduce
an environment from my machine to your
machine to wherever we have it on the
cloud so that we can be confident that
our scientific conclusions that are
derived from code executing in these
environments is valid and consistent and
finally we think tools like vagrant and
ansible and others can help researchers
develop these scientific environments
that they need to be productive moving
forward thanks very much really
appreciate your time excellent
presentation I have really kind of to my
baby comments or questions more on the
open Sciences front one kind of
philosophical and the other pragmatic
and I'd like to hear your opinions on
the philosophical side you know we've
seen over and over just devastating in
some cases corruptions of data and
analyses fabrications even in fact
recently there was a two hundred million
dollars worth of cancer research was
funded and it was based on fraudulent
manipulation of data in this area and
when you think about that at a
philosophical level it has to be linked
to this incredible emphasis on
monetizing fundamental research in a in
a closed environment there are forces
that want to capture intellectual
property early and it causes a huge
issue so I it really kind of goes to
maybe an underlying element of this and
the second kind of question is on the
more pragmatic level every time you turn
the corner and you try to look up some
research whether it's online or wherever
you see these wonderful articles you
want to sit down and read these articles
to understand it a little more maybe
gain access to the
data to understand what they've done and
you pop up with you know you could
download this file to clone a PDF for
fifty nine dollars and ninety-nine cents
or you can look at it for you know two
days for thirty nine dollars and all of
this research is funded either by
institutions or foundations or the
government and then you turn it around
and at a very pragmatic level you lose
access to it because of these these
barriers so you know I'd like to hear
what you guys have to say about that so
to start with our opinions are our own
and not those of our of our employer you
should be a librarian these these are
the issues I think that we're struggling
with in a lot of ways and I want to give
back a chance to respond that the one
thing that I would say from a
philosophical standpoint is and what
we've been trying to advocate on our
campus as we've made an argument for
open practice is that we don't need to
just flip the switch and go all open
progress can be made if we adopt a
spectrum approach where we at least try
to make progress toward being open as
much as we can there's incremental
benefit to be gained while working
toward the philosophical goal of being
truly open but I just want to comment on
the first half of your question which is
um there's there's a notion of a legacy
gap in relation to open science this
idea that we are in a moment in history
where infrastructure which includes
policy and includes the way that
metadata is handled includes everything
associated with research has not caught
up with the digital infrastructure
possible so things are in use that
policy and infrastructure have not
caught up with and something similar
happened in the Middle Ages with
medieval guilds particularly in Europe
where in order for a guild to really
assert itself they would keep
information about the way that they did
something specific very close to home
and it was very difficult for
practitioners to move between guilds the
thing that enabled that motion of
information was patent law so we're in a
moment prior to patent law basically
it's just not
patent law in this case it's a broader
infrastructure shift so philosophically
that's where we are and I don't know
that we really have any conclusions on
that from our standpoint it's just a
very complex moment in the history of
science and back back to your question
about the pragmatic issue of being
charged for data we have a number of
initiatives in our own library towards
trying to move people toward publishing
and open access journals and open access
data repositories these come with their
own challenges where researchers are
asked to front the publication cost or
the perceived publication cost of their
research libraries try to be advocates
for that work as best as we can we see
it as it we see it as a terrible crime I
mean I have to admit it's it's extremely
frustrating to see impactful research
like that be be constrained in a way
that people can apply it the whole first
principles of science that we mentioned
is this idea that progress is built on
the shoulders of those that come come
before you if you can't access their
work you can't build on it it doesn't
really solve the question but great
questions
this is more of a question on the
technical implementation side it sounds
like based on the way you're using
ansible and vagrant that something like
docker might actually meet your needs
better because it would be sort of the
containerized provisioning of Linux and
configuration in one fell swoop
especially with recent advancements in
stable versions of docker running on all
environments not just Linux um so could
you comment on why you made the specific
architectural choice as opposed to
sitting outside bugger sure sure so
we've also been investigating dr. for
some of our other work for the
applications that we write we just
weren't along in in our implementation
to apply it at this point I agree that
from a scalability standpoint docker
kind of meets this intersection very
nicely and it's certainly an approach
worth considering yeah we didn't roll it
out for any technical reason it's a
socio socio-economical concern it was
the timing of the workshop thank you hi
this is a really exciting talk to me I'm
not a scientist but I've been studying
this is there I know that you need
constraints is such an expansive project
that being able to just work the ncsu is
probably a lot but I would love to see
an opportunity for people outside of the
ncsu fins to access your work what what
concepts you have about sort of allowing
some portals into what you're doing to
the outer community everything we do is
open we publish openly on github so we
do encourage community members to
comment on our work and to contribute
ideas yeah we're at the phase when our
with our program design where I think
some of those opportunities for broader
community participation will be more
visible this investigation has really
just started with two of us as a portion
of our time and we're moving towards you
know in conjunction with a variety of
other initiatives happening in the
library around issues of open access
research data management open source
software so this particular focus is
still emergent
in our library but we'll try to put a
little bit more up on a library website
perhaps too so show some access points
to this thanks so when you said receive
costs to researchers of open access I'm
curious are there ways to make those
costs go down because it's like looks
like it's way more to have something
open I guess I was being overly cynical
I would perhaps a mistake to make when a
mic isn't in your mouth I I was
suggesting that perhaps we don't have a
clear picture on the true cost of
publishing and that costs that are
passed on to researchers or libraries
may not reflect the true cost so thank
you very much this is a great talk
thanks thanks very much